[Music]
christmas will be looking a little
different this year
but there's one thing you can change and
that's making a stress-free meal
okay jc stopped by la bonita to show us
how
that's right la bonita has everything
you need from
pre-cooked meals to marinated meats to
desserts and drinks and we're going to
taste it all today
first things first celeste it is always
great to see you and today a big
congratulations
is in order because la bonita best of
las vegas yes
we did we are voted 2020 vesta las
vegas on hispanic grocery stores we're
very very excited
you made that happen you have my vote i
love you guys let's talk about the food
we got we're going to start off with
some of the pre-season meats what do we
have in front of us well you know la
bonita has its secret sauce and we
cannot leave you hanging this holiday
season so we have
prepared meals for you for you to just
put it in the oven and get it ready
we have some wonderful chicken over here
we have turkey
we have pork and of course in our secret
sauce the secret sauce here lavonita
what is what is
what is the meat stuffing you got meat
stuffed inside of me so there's
me stuff and the chicken i and i love
this too because
when you're cooking at your house you'll
get the smell and the seasonings of la
bonita
taking over your home which is great on
christmas day now if you don't want to
do any cooking at all you have pre-made
meals what are some of the meals we have
yes
we have so many specials these holiday
seasons but of course we want to bring
you the best of the best for you so
right now we have this wonderful special
which is
eight stuffed chicken breasts wow that
comes with
mashed potatoes and it comes with
macaroni salad
for only 29.99 eight of them for under
30.
entire family for 30 bucks it's a meal i
know i will
yeah all right so what do we have what's
this one in front of me this is the soup
i've been smelling it all afternoon
you've been smelling it and you actually
have never tried this one jk so i am
very excited for you to try it this is
our famous
possole posole is a very very
traditional
mexican dish it's almost like a stew and
it has pork in it
and it has beans and that one is you get
five
orders of that size of plate
with the drink and tortillas and chips
for 39.99
how good is that that is delicious the
seasoning and the spices in that soup
just so good
and this is one of the drinks we have
here what's this drink that is the
famous champurrado the champurado is
so good made here you know what it's
great for breakfast and churros and we
have churros here too
i love for breakfast with the churros
this is something i can see christmas
morning coming down having some of this
it's like hot cocoa on christmas morning
as you're like
gifts and everything is so good yes that
is exactly right we've got about 30
seconds we're missing your tamales
oh my gosh tamales oh
right now we have a dozen for 19.99 you
we're doing social distances
so here we go
you can order this online curbside
pickup you don't even have to get out of
your car you can just order online get
your order before christmas
how good is that i didn't unwrap mine
but you're so good okay
i'm learning this fernandez is slowly
learning the process it is still good
is that brian sending back to you guys
in the studio
merry christmas need to pass one of
those over here all right there are
seven la beneath the supermarkets in the
vegas valley click on bonitamarkets.com
to find the location nearest you